jeudi à washington sur les marches de la
cour suprême
donald trump se recueille devant le
cercueil de nikon démocrate ruth bader
ginsburg avec en fond des remontrances
[Applaudissements]
vote him out traduisez voter contre lui
plusieurs opposants ont fait le
déplacement pour exhorter également le
président américain a honoré le souhait
de l'une des figures de la lutte pour
l'égalité homme femme décédée vendredi
18 septembre à l'âge de 87 ans la juge
démocrate aurait confié à sa petite
fille avant de mourir ne pas vouloir
être remplacé avant qu'un nouveau
président soit investie en janvier
prochain
je pense que c'était juste des champs
politique on pouvait à peine les
entendre nous on était quelqu'un a dit
qu'il y avait des slogans scandés
mais il était juste à côté des médias
mais on ne pouvait vraiment pas on
entendait à peine on a entendu un bruit
mais il n'était pas très fort elle
tirait ceci je pense que samedi après
midi à 17 heures ce sera un jour très
important dans l'histoire de notre pays
je pense que ce sera un jour vraiment
monumental un très bon choix une
décision stratégique pour le
milliardaire républicain à 38 jours de
l'élection présidentielle selon les
grands médias américain donald trump
aurait choisi la magistrate
emiko nibards est catholique pratiquante
de 48 ans mère de sept enfants est
opposé notamment à l'avortement un
signal fort en direction de l'électorat
religieux conservateur soutient il y a
quatre ans de l'actuel président
américain est notre nom circule celui de
barbara l'agoa
né en floride est d'origine cubaine de
la trup on jouerait alors la carte
hispanique dans cet état du sud souvent
jugé décisif pour remporter une élection
présidentielle
robin m nous allons nommer le candidat
qui espérons le sera sur ce tribunal
pendant 50 ans
la seule chose dont je suis sûr c'est
que ce sera une femme est ce que cela
vous convient et si quelqu'un à une
objection à cela s'il vous plaît lever
la main il ya beaucoup de l'ach ici et
regardez vous messieurs je ne vois pas
il n'y a pas un seul homme ici qui ait
le courage de lever la main pas un seul
les neuf juges qui composent la cour
suprême des etats unis sont nommés par
le président et confirmés à leur poste
elle vit par le sénat sur les huit
membres actuels cinq ont été nommés par
des présidents républicains dans deux
par donald trump et 3 par des démocrates
avec cette nouvelle nomination la haute
juridiction qui arbitre les grands
débats de la société américaine comme
l'avortement le port d'armes ou encore
la peine de mort s'annonce plus que
jamais conservatrice le sénat devra donc
entériné dans les prochaines semaines ce
choix décisif
un sénat à majorité républicaine